well some folks on the right are
ecstatic with Glee today because Kanye
West is saying some things that they
agree with even Kim Kardashian it's
cotton even Kim Kardashian has gotten
favorable coverage from the right
because of all this now let's remember
something about the right the right of
which I am a member
unless I'm imagining things unless I've
been hallucinating for the last 20 years
or so I'm pretty sure that the right has
spent a very long time insisting that
celebrities are dumb and stupid and
they're morons and their political
opinions don't matter and they need to
just shut up and sing and entertain us
because we don't want to we don't want
to hear them injecting politics and
everything just shut up just shut up
just shut up that's what we've been
saying we've said it a million times
over and over and over again to these
celebrities it's not no it has not been
as much as we'd like to pretend
otherwise our message to celebrities and
singers and pop stars athletes our
message to them has not been oh I
disagree with what you're saying let's
have let's engage let's have a
discussion no that's how it hasn't been
our message our message has been very
explicitly you shouldn't be talking
about this subject you don't know
anything about it your job is a tenor to
entertain us so just shut up that's been
our message but then what happens the
moment one of these celebrities says
something we agree with while we're in
the midst of shouting shut up all you
just stop talking about this and then
one of them responds oh but wait a
second I actually agree with you on this
one single point well that was okay well
hold on okay you come here you can talk
you yes you please stand up on this
stage this platform repeat it again so
everyone can hear it no no you guys over
there you're Meryl Streep and Colin
Kaepernick you still shut up you nobody
wants to hear you but you'll go ahead
please yes please talk please please I
mean Kanye
a few years ago when you were talking
about how George Bush hates black people
you needed to shut up then because
nobody cares about your political
opinions but now oh yes please share
your political opinions with everyone
this is huge everyone listen to this
person listen to this celebrity he's a
celebrity his opinion matters and then
two seconds later you're a celebrity
your opinion doesn't matter our
perspective changes very quickly from
shut up and sing to please be our
president and I know listen I know what
I'm saying right now is not
crowd-pleasing
it's not crowd-pleasing because i'm
criticizing us i mean i'm criticizing
you and me and i know that when someone
watches a video a video on facebook or
listens to a podcast what they really
want to hear is criticisms of everybody
else what they're really looking for is
a moment where you and I are talking
about how terrible everyone else is I
mean you and I haven't figured out but
all those other people let's talk about
how terrible they are what I've noticed
is that the moment I turn the mirror
around on us and say oh but look at this
this thing that we're doing maybe we
have problems too that's when there's
suddenly a revolt and it's oh stop being
negative stop judging right now I notice
that I am only negative and judging and
all these things when I'm criticizing us
what if I stick with criticizing
everyone else well then the then there's
no problem but I don't care because this
is just I mean we are on the right we
are done we are blatantly contradicting
ourselves not just on this issue but on
so many issues especially recently we
have just turned into utter and complete
hypocrites just changing our tune on so
many things
all of a sudden opportunistically and
forfeiting our integrity in the process
and I don't really care if pointing that
out turns everyone against me I don't
really care because it's true
now in Kanye West's case he's been
tweeting a bunch of controversial things
and he does have I think he has new
music coming out soon so I'm sure it's
just a coincidence that he's saying all
this controversial stuff and getting
attention while he's got music to
promote I'm sure there's no connection
there whatsoever right and he's tweeted
some nice things about free expression
free speech etc but mainly the thing
that has gotten him attention and has
gotten him favorable has made him a
darling of the right is that he's
expressed support for Donald Trump and
Trump responded on Twitter and there was
this little exchange this back and forth
between Kanye West and Donald Trump and
that is really what sent some folks on
the right into rapturous seizures is
when they saw that and that's the only
conservative thing he said conservative
thing as far as I can tell and I'm not
an expert on his tweets I haven't read
them very carefully I only know what
he's tweeting because a lot of
conservatives in my Twitter feed have
just been retweeting the heck out of
them they've just retweeted everything
you said and again these are the same
conservatives who have spent years the
exact same ones who have spent years
telling celebrities to shutup their
political opinions don't matter and now
they're just all day retweeting Kanye
West and so I know that he's also I mean
he's talked about how truth is
subjective he's talked a lot about how
the key to happiness is self-love and
you know it's it's within yourself self
affirmation you know the self
affirmation type of typical Hollywood
tripe but with Kanye West's affinity for
Trump we're told that this is a sign
that the right is winning the culture
and this is how we win the culture I'm
told we win it through celebrities who
like Donald Trump it was the same thing
with Roseanne Roseanne and her show
whether we're talking about the new
version or the old version it promotes
all kinds of far
propaganda it is a far left show
cross-dressing nine-year-olds that is
extreme left-wing degeneracy being
promoted and mainstreamed and somehow
they've convinced conservatives to not
only watch it but to applaud it
incredibly the show in the past has also
historically promoted abortion gay
marriage on an honor and Roseann herself
is a far left nutcase she wished death
on everyone who eats chick-fil-a she
said she hopes they all get cancer
because chick-fil-a is anti-gay she
hasn't changed her tune she's still a
far left nutcase it just so happens that
she also likes Donald Trump and we've
decided that none of that other stuff
matters the only thing that matters is
that she likes Donald Trump now this
this may surprise you but I'm gonna be
the odd man out here I don't agree
this idea that Roseanne and Kanye West
and all this stuff they're the ones
helping us win the culture I don't agree
and in fact I don't see the right
winning the culture there's been a lot
of talk on the right recently about
we're winning our message is winning yes
no it's not look around you what are you
talking about it's winning I'll tell you
what's actually happening the right is
not winning the culture the right is
becoming more like the left the right is
just fighting to be the new left the
right thinks that it's making the
culture more conservative but all it's
really doing is is becoming more liberal
itself thus it sees itself more
reflected in the culture because it has
stooped down and rid itself of most
everything that used to differentiate it
from the culture
let me try to explain my meeting a
little more and I think first we have to
ask a very simple question what is the
culture war about what does it mean to
win the culture what are we fighting for
what are we fighting against how do we
win what is winning as I see it and as I
think almost every conservative used to
see it the real problem with the culture
and the central battle in the culture is
spiritual and moral decay that is the
problem and the collapse of the family
is part of that the loss of the sanctity
of life is part of that the destruction
of marriage is part of that the
abandonment of religion is part of that
the proliferation of perversion and
degeneracy
that's part of that pornography as part
of that gender identity that's part of
all of this is part of the main battle
this thing the spiritual moral decay
which has emptied our civilization
hollowed it out made it a shell of what
it once was
this is what's killing our civilization
other issues are important but not as
important gun rights taxes immigration
those are crucial topics yes but but but
even if we had all the gun rights and
the border was closed and taxes were low
which would be great believe me it would
mean nothing at all if the culture is
still in a state of moral rot because
then we would still just be wandering
into the abyss not sure of what sort of
people were supposed to be or what the
point of life even is and we're just
wandering into destruction only we
happen to have a gun and more money in
our wallet and fewer illegals walking
next to us which fine but it means
nothing if we've given up on the one
thing that means everything which is
truth yes we we need to have the right
it's important to fight for rights
because we need to have them and why why
is it important fight for rights because
we need to have the right to be the sort
of people we should be
but then the next level more
fundamentally than that we need to know
what sort of people we should be in
other words the fight for freedom is
important only because freedom gives a
person the ability to realize their
god-given potential but if we take
freedom and we do not pursue that
potential and indeed we reject that
there is a potential that there is a God
or anything that there is anything to
strive for then we're just going to end
up even worse than we would have been
without the freedom in the first place
this is why it's it's not enough and as
as I've seen this is something
conservatives have been doing more and
more is as you've noticed conservatives
more and more they they're not fighting
for what is right they're just fighting
for rights I don't know if you've
noticed that transition because you're
just getting rid of one little word
there is but it's huge not fighting for
what is right we're just fighting for
rights an example of how this works is
you'll notice that pretty much any
conservative will get up and they'll
fight for the right they'll fight for
people's right to be against gay
marriage they'll fight for the rights of
bakers who don't want to bake gay
wedding cakes they'll fight for those
rights on the basis of free speech and
freedom of religion which is good
because that's really important but what
they won't do is they won't then proceed
to explain why it is right to fight for
the protection of marriage they won't do
that
they'll fight for the right but not for
what is right and that's a big problem
because our main message should be or
take abortion for instance yes we should
have the right to voice our pro-life
views so if you're standing up for our
right to voice our pro-life views thank
you
but more important than that is the fact
that we are right about those views and
so that's our main message our main
message is that I have the right to say
these things
our primary message should be I am right
about these things and that's why you
should listen to me not just because I
have the right to say it
but because I'm right in saying it and
in conservatives have have just have not
been as willing to make that point so
then just look at what's happened in our
culture over the last several decades
we've taken all this freedom all of this
great and wonderful freedom and we've
used it to destroy the family destroy
marriage destroy babies destroy the
church destroy ourselves with our
freedom we've invented the drug epidemic
the divorce epidemic the suicide
epidemic the porn epidemic the
depression epidemic on and on and on we
have the freedom to satisfy our desires
yet we don't know what we should desire
what will bring us true joy and
fulfillment so we run around just
indulging every whim and we plunge ever
deeper and deeper into despair and ruin
because of it in fact we we are we have
so much freedom to indulge our whims and
we have so many desires that now what we
do in our culture is we plunge deep into
the recesses of our subconscious and we
bring to the surface just every
degrading perverse desire we can find
and we and we present it to the world
and we fight for the right to indulge it
meanwhile nobody's happy nobody knows
why we're even here what's the point of
anything I'm not arguing against freedom
here this is not an argument against
freedom this is an argument for the
thing that is deeper than freedom and
that thing fundamentally is truth virtue
God morality that's what we should be
fighting for and the problem is that the
right is less and less concerned with
fighting for those things for truth God
morality virtue and so it only continues
to lose the actual battle the real
battle the battle for the thing that
matters we're losing because we've
surrendered it and we won't even fight
it anymore this is the less primary
objective is the destruction of truth
and morality the destruction of the
moral fabric of our civilization that is
the left's main primary objective so if
you are not fighting against them on
that battlefield fighting against their
efforts to undermine the moral fabric of
our civilization if you're not fighting
them there then you're not fighting them
you're really not doing anything you may
be arguing with them on a million other
topics but if you will not dive in on
that point and say no this is right this
is moral we are fighting for this
because that if you won't do that then
you're not you're not fighting them
you're not doing anything in fact I
would say even you're a coward and
you're not really helping so
how do kanye west's and Roseanne factor
into this I mean not in a very important
way but what I see here in the Wrights
love affair with leftist celebrities who
happen to like Donald Trump I see a
symptom of this problem
the right will you know hold their
affinity for Trump and maybe their
affinity for free speech they'll hold
those things up as the most important
things further marginalizing further
ignoring further surrendering the battle
for truth virtue morality and God the
right will embrace some figure who is
fully a proponent of degeneracy and
moral relativism and every other evil
known to man and and the right will
embrace them just because they said some
positive stuff about Trump and on the
other side if there's a figure who is
really fighting the battle against
degeneracy and moral relativism and
fighting for truth and fighting for
those things yet who is not sufficiently
onboard with Trump well they're gonna
they're going to be alienated and exiled
that's what we've done we'll kick people
out I mean they could be engaged just
down in the trenches on this central
battlefield here but if they're not
saying the right things about Trump we
say get out we don't want you so I think
you see we are not winning we've
surrendered we've given up
we've given up and that's what allows us
to you know celebrate because some
celebrity likes Trump as if that will
have any bearing whatsoever on the one
thing that matters but it seems the one
thing that matters doesn't really matter
to us anymore and so what I see
happening right now is it used to be you
had the moral relativists and then you
had those on the other side who fought
for objective morality and truth and now
what I think is gonna happen is you have
just two factions who are both moral
relativists fighting for domination and
control not fighting for truth or
anything not not fighting for anything
beyond that but just fighting for
domination and control of the culture so
that their brand their variety of
relativism may may be supreme I don't
see any kind of real victory in that
personally so I hate to be a party
pooper but there it is thanks for
listening everybody I'll talk to you
tomorrow